Hey,
what's going on is bill burn?
It's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
April 14th,
2000 and flood a,
uh,
Jesus Christ.
I've been sitting here.
Okay.
Uh,
I'm still,
uh,
in France.
This is the last fucking week I'm in France.
Okay.
Um,
last couple of days here.
So that's why I'm still using the garage band thing and it sounds a little
weird,
but I've been sitting here for fucking a half hour.
Okay.
Waiting for the lovely Nia to leave the apartment so I can do the Goddamn
podcast.
She's probably going to come back here in the end,
but uh,
I just,
I mean,
does anything take fucking longer?
I know this is a hacky bit and it's been done a zillion times by every comic out
there was a fucking sweater and works totally clean.
I see this and women do that,
but there's anything fucking take longer.
Then a woman getting ready to leave.
I actually had a die and laughing.
She grabs his fucking bag and the amount of shit she's putting in it as,
okay,
you're going on an excursion.
She had medicine in there.
She grabbed like fucking three different things to put on her head or around her
neck,
scarves,
fucking whatevers.
I don't know.
Why does it take him?
So,
um,
I just kept saying,
get the fuck out of here
anyways,
so I didn't know what the fuck I'm going to talk about this week because I
haven't been doing shit.
I haven't watched shit.
I haven't talked on his cell phone in forever.
Um,
I'm completely out of the loop.
Like I finally just checked in with the NHL,
nhl.com to see what the hell was going on.
Um,
oh,
and by the way,
if you lived over here,
uh,
you would,
you would get into soccer or football.
Uh,
you'd get into rugby,
you'd watch all those sports Ed,
you'd enjoy it.
They're great games.
That's what I realized once a Ben over here fucking long enough.
And at some point you have to watch your goddamn sporting event,
you know,
and uh,
you go in there and everybody's into the thing and you just,
you just get sucked into it.
Like,
I'm,
I'm actually rubber necking down when I walked by screens and there's a soccer
game on and I never want I,
you know,
I don't watch it at shit.
Um,
and late last night I did catch,
uh,
the ending of the masters.
I think Bubba Watson won.
I hope he did.
I saw when he birdied any went up by three and then I checked in on the Internet
when he had two holes to play and he seemed like he had it.
Um,
but I promised my wife I would come back here and watch.
I swear to God the Devil Wears Prada.
Yeah.
You know,
trying to keep the peace.
I agree to come back and watch this fucking film
and uh,
I gotta tell you it was worse than I thought it was going to be.
I figured if Meryl Streep is in it,
you know,
it's gotta be good on some level.
Yeah.
Watch that movie or somebody,
somebody can,
somebody,
actually,
I don't want to do this to a guy.
Is there a woman out there that can do this?
Can you somehow cut that movie down to how many times a seem starts with one or
two people walking fast into the scene.
Okay.
That whole fucking,
the whole ridiculousness of fashion in general and these fucking people walking
in,
okay,
I need six dresses of this at Blah,
blah,
Blah Blah and all that.
And like,
I couldn't watch the movie because within the first three minutes I'm yelling at
the screen
to Meryl Streep's character.
You don't get it yourself.
You silver haired can't.
Right.
So Nias is punching me.
And she was just so ridiculously mean in that movie that after a while I didn't
have any sympathy for the big brown eyed girl who sat there getting abused.
So finally,
after like a half hour,
I start like not enough.
Granted I got a couple of beers in me,
you know,
more than a couple of,
okay,
I've been drinking this shit over here.
1664 it's hilarious with typical Americans needs sit and they go,
was that the year,
the French Revolution?
And the only reason why I knew it wasn't it was because I just,
you know,
being in France,
you stumble across some shit about that.
Again,
I think that was 1789 so we looked it up to see what the significance was and it
was just the year that the brewery started.
So anyway,
so I've been knocking those things back.
Those have been my core light over here,
the 1664 whatever the fuck he Ernest and anyways,
so I lasted about maybe 45 minutes into it and the dude for Martha Rogers in it
and they didn't give him anything to do,
the poor bastard.
All he had to do is just sit there and be like,
what?
She was being a bitch again.
Can I make you some food?
Do you look hot?
I want to fuck you.
That was his scene every fucking time you saw him.
Um,
so anyways,
you like,
I'm reviewing this movie that came up,
I thought like three years ago,
I guess it was like 10 years ago,
but so anyway,
so I pass out slash falls and right before I go to sleep I say to Nia and go,
wake me up when she tells this woman to go fuck herself.
And she goes,
okay,
I will.
And she didn't,
you know,
I guess why would you,
why would you wake up somebody who finally nodded off who's been calling?
One of the main characters is silver haired content.
I understood the decision,
you know,
but the next day I woke up and I said,
so what did finally say to her?
And she goes,
actually,
she didn't say anything.
She just sort of walked away.
What a horrible movie.
MMM.
Oh.
Anyways,
uh,
where we're staying,
the guy who runs the place is from a,
you some London,
and he was talking about some,
that Woody Allen movie that had won an Oscar.
I was downstairs.
He goes,
did you,
did you say that?
I go,
yeah,
yeah.
And I go,
yeah,
I liked it.
I thought it was great,
and he goes,
you thought was great.
She goes,
I thought it was absolute rubbish.
I love when he goes,
people say that rubbish,
absolute rubbish didn't go anywhere.
It's like it movie starts.
The woman's crazy and I can't do the English accent.
He basically said in the end of the movie,
she's still crazy.
He goes,
I thought a movie's supposed to lift you up and take your sub where he said,
the movie didn't take you anywhere.
And I do admit,
I,
I couldn't argue with this criticism of it.
I still liked it.
Oh Jesus.
What am I fucking Siskel and Ebert over here?
Um,
I got nothing to talk about people.
I really don't.
So as I was mentioning,
I checked in with the,
uh,
with the NHL to see what was,
what was going on.
And Lo and behold,
it's time for the playoffs.
So having not watched any of the shit
for weeks,
now I'm going to give you my picks.
These are my picks are right.
First round.
We got the Bro.
It's airway go bro wins.
Here we go first.
The Detroit Red Wings.
Who are now in the east for those of you who have been sleeping.
Um,
yeah.
I don't know.
I think I'm going to go with the [inaudible] on that one.
Then you got the fucking hated habs against the lightening.
I'd take the habs.
I think Pittsburgh is going to beat the blue jackets and I liked the flyers to
beat the fucking rages.
MMM.
Over in the West.
The best thing about the west,
if you're a fan of a team from the east is that they're all going to beat the
shit out of each other and only one's going to be left in the finals.
That's the only thing I can say about that because,
uh,
they look fucking strong out there.
Uh,
I'm gonna say,
uh,
Minnesota and an upset over the ABS.
Uh,
unfortunately I don't think Saint Louis is going to get by Chicago and polling
for those guys to finally fucking make a run.
Uh,
and I'm going to beat Dallas and I think that kings are going to beat San Jose
and those are my picks with absolutely no information behind them.
I have not watched a hockey game in two weeks.
So there you go.
No information behind those pics.
I'm picking them like a fucking,
like a check when you know what that means.
Most of those have probably come in,
don't,
don't put any money on it cause I don't,
I don't want to deal with that.
So you're probably asking yourself,
so they're fucking French.
Freddy,
what the Hell did you do this week?
I continued butchering their language.
I picked up to new new expressions are a couple of words.
Uh,
an old plats means a flat water.
Okay.
Uh,
excuse me while I miss sue.
is Yuval Jay own old plats?
Mitzi.
You know,
it's funny too,
I noticed the way they sit,
they don't say we,
they say why
right way.
And then it means like,
yeah,
so if you say we,
that's like you going yes.
And then they immediately know,
even with that one word that you're a tourist.
Forget about your fucking Bruins hat that you're wearing it,
you know,
they say,
would you like a beer?
And you go,
yes instead of,
yeah,
yes,
I would like a beer.
Mr. Thank you.
If you please.
But they've been cool as hell.
So anyways,
um,
I actually went out to,
uh,
Omaha beach this weekend.
I got to tell you something.
Um,
if you ever get a chance,
you got to do it.
It was
okay.
Uh,
you know what a,
it's not really something you can,
I can't express in words.
It was,
it was,
uh,
unbelievably moving.
It was iconic.
Um,
I,
I don't,
I don't know where to start all week.
We set up a private tour cause I can't stand,
I hate group tours because when you go on group tours,
you know,
aside from seeing fat people in Jean shorts,
there's going to be that Douche who like has read up on this subject in,
is actually going to try to out nerd the nerd given the fucking tour.
And you know,
which all it does is just drag the tour out.
Like,
you know,
I mean,
I'm into it,
but I don't need to hear every fucking nookie nook and cranny,
you know,
just give me the fucking bullet points.
Give me the highlights.
Alright.
And with that,
if I want to go deeper into this shit,
I'll do it on my own.
You know what,
you know if there's going to be somebody standing at dress like some civil war
reenactor right.
Just that shit.
So I don't want to deal with that.
And uh,
and then also if you have a question,
you don't have to wait for anybody else.
So basically why I choose to do it like that.
So basically you show up
and uh,
the driver takes you.
We stayed in a,
is it by you?
You,
I don't know where
the hell it is.
I don't know how you say it.
Um,
oh,
this is fucking hilarious.
So I rented a car.
Um,
once again,
control freak.
I don't have to take a fucking shuttle out there with another 20 Douche bags.
I don't,
all right.
So we rented this car one way from a,
we took the train from Paris up to buy you.
And uh,
it was amazing.
Just an amazing ride,
you know,
beautiful scenery and that type of thing.
Unless you're looking at somebody's house,
then it's always ugly.
Houses near train tracks are always ugly.
Cause basically what you're seeing is the backyard is somebody who can't afford
to not live right next to the fucking train tracks.
But when you get out of the towns,
the scenery is beautiful.
Um,
so we get out it,
uh,
by you or whatever,
it's what I'm going to call bay.
You buy you whatever the fuck you call it.
And I go to the,
uh,
the rental car place and now we're in the shit.
Okay.
In Paris,
she run into people that can speak English.
We're fucking out there and you know,
for the most part nobody speaks any English.
And uh,
when it was actually fun,
I kind of learned what my wife does when she talks to people.
Like she doesn't understand most of what they're saying.
She just looks at what they're doing.
And at some point they'll give away kind of,
they'll betray basically what the fuck they're saying.
And what it is is not freaking out.
And you kind of got to sit in the pocket and wait for them to point at
something,
do some sort of shoulder shrug because you're renting a car,
which you've done a zillion times.
So you know what happens the,
they basically say,
hey,
how are you?
And you're like,
Hey,
my name is so and so.
I want a car.
And then they'll say,
the next thing is do you have an id or do you have a reservation number?
You kind of know this series of questions and there's just something about,
uh,
there'll be either one word that you pick up or just something that they,
they,
they point or something.
Like I asked this woman where the bathroom was,
we went out to this fucking Jesus Christ.
We went out to this,
I don't know what you call it,
what do you call it when people just take their old shit?
And they just,
they all go to the same dirt parking lot of bizarre of a market.
We went to this fucking market.
So the great thing about this market was they had it in the same place in the
middle of the country every fucking week.
And,
uh,
so somebody built like a little restaurant up there.
We could go drink.
It was the greatest market I've ever been to.
Right.
Sitting there waiting around all this shit.
I got to tell you,
my wife find pumps,
some gems in there,
but I just don't have the patients.
It's just sitting out on a damn table.
It just looks like shit to me.
So I went in and had a couple of beers and a,
this woman didn't speak any English.
And finally I asked her,
uh,
you know,
way late,
late toilet,
and she's still looking at me like,
what?
And I'm like,
Jesus Christ,
I can't even convey that to you,
the fucking toilet CBU play,
right?
So,
uh,
she starts going a mile a minute and French and I'm like,
I'm fucked.
I don't,
and she's pointing out the door and I have no idea what she's saying.
And then she kinda does this loop around sort of motion with their hand.
And I'm like,
oh,
it's outside and around the fucking corner and low bow that was,
yeah,
WC water closet.
That's what they call it.
Yeah.
They call it a water closet.
Cause that sounds much better than uh,
than a shit check,
whatever the fuck you'd call it.
Right.
So I go in there and uh,
I didn't have my phone on me.
I really wish I could have taken a picture.
I basically,
you stand on this porcelain thing and there's a hole in the ground you just pee
into.
It's like these two porcelain,
like things you're supposed to stand on.
I'm like,
I'm not fucking standing on those things.
Okay.
So I stood behind the porcelain thing and I got a Little Act God,
Ya know,
like Larry Bird and the three point contest,
just one after another going right in the hole.
And you know,
I missed the last 10 seconds.
Um,
anyways,
what was my point?
Oh,
so anyway,
so we got to,
we got to obey you,
buy you whatever the fuck you call it.
And um,
oh yeah,
so all that's right.
So I'm renting a car and this is something that I've known,
I've noticed now that is international.
Anytime you rent a car one way,
okay,
that location is going to give you the fucking,
that car that nobody wants to rent.
It's going to be a fucked up color.
It's going to be a fucked up model.
Something about it.
You know what these people rented.
We rent,
we're two people,
that's all we uh,
they gave us this giant Mercedes van that I got nine passenger fucking van and
I'm driving through these little European streets with this thing.
Yeah.
With like two pieces of luggage all the way in the back.
And I know what you think and we'll build some Mercedes.
This is what you don't realize about Mercedes is they have a lot of low end
fucking under powered cars that they don't send over to the United States.
A lot of those,
uh,
I'd,
I'd just,
they just feel they can't compete with Honda's.
Toyota's and I dunno,
whatever the Americans are putting out or what.
But this thing was an underpowered hunk of shit with the Mercedes emblem on the
steering wheel.
And a,
I was turning,
I can't tell you how many fucking times I clipped a corner trying to drive this
bus around the corner.
So,
um,
long story short,
I'm driving this giant Partridge family,
Mercedes Benz truck down the Damn Street.
We get to our hotel,
uh,
everything,
everything's great.
And um,
we take a quick cat nap and then,
uh,
this guy shows up,
this guy from Scotland and he took us on this unbelievable tour of basically,
um,
Omaha beach in this other area.
Some point,
I already forget the name of it.
And this guy was an absolute maniac,
absolutely obsessed with World War II and obsessed with d day.
And he had all these photographs that he had.
He blown up from other books and was talking about misinformation and,
and it was an incredible tour.
The first point of the tour,
you actually like the pill boxes and stuff,
you know,
with the Germans had their machine guns or it was a little barracks.
It was a place to keep their ammunition.
This still there,
you know,
the guns aren't there,
but basically where they were is still there and you get to walk into these
things like on the ground where these cement bags that Germans had put,
you know,
when it's rained and it own,
it all turned hard and out.
Like you can't even if you look at him actually look like rocks,
they look like white rocks but they're actually bags of cement and you just look
in that going like a German soldier,
set those fucking things down.
Okay.
And then all the events happened in the,
here they sit 70 years later it,
it gave you goosebumps and um,
this guy knew all the history.
He goes,
this is where private so-and-so came in.
He threw a grenade,
you can see the shrapnel on the wall and you're looking and there's the fucking
shrapnel.
We walked into this one bunker and right to the right was a little like probably
just enough for someone to stand.
And it had like a,
and it was about two inches below the floor that you were at as far as like
where the floor was there.
And it was a little shower and our tour guy said Hitler got gassed in World War
One.
So he made sure that all of these bunkers had showers in case cause I guess,
you know,
it was such a horrific experience for him.
You know,
that he made sure like none of the troops were going to get caught out there
like he did.
And uh,
it was just really bizarre,
like human moment from one of the most evil people on the fucking planet.
It's like,
wow,
that guy actually did something nice.
So they go people,
he's not all bad when you walk into a German bunker,
he made sure they all had a little shower.
So there you go.
There's,
there's one good thing.
He's still has six to 9 million,
you know,
bad things in the other raw part of the ledger.
But he does have that one thick.
I bet that was the thing after he blew his brains out,
if there is an afterlife and God was giving him shit,
I bet he just kept coming back to that.
But,
but,
but I went to,
I put on shower,
did not have to do that.
Uh,
you know,
he lost his temper and started yelling at God.
You know,
God just sat there shaking his head.
But part of them had to be like,
I made this,
what the fuck was I doing on that day?
And then he just presses that little button under his desk,
which is why would it be under his desk?
Like what's he nervous?
He's running shit.
He's like the dawn of all dawn's.
I bet he just let them talk.
Sit there,
stammering dancing around,
sweating before he fucking open the trap door.
Um,
anyways,
what am I talking about here?
Let me,
let me do a little,
a little bit of advertising and I'll get back to this shit here and I apologize
for the sound of the clicking.
I know this is annoying,
but what do you,
what do you want from me?
Well,
belt,
we'd like a professional podcast.
Well then you don't want listen to a professional podcast.
I'll listen to this one.
All right.
Hulu plus everyone,
you've probably tried Hulu on your computer.
You plus is so much more with Hugh Hulu.
Plus you can watch current seasons,
season episodes of your favorite shows like modern family,
the daily show and scandal and watch every episode episode of shows like
Nashville lost and doctor who basically all the big ones that everybody watches.
You get ad free movies and kids show to get shows to.
Now more than ever,
there is so much to watch.
Take total control with Hulu plus the stream these shows and thousands and
thousands more as much as you want,
wherever you want.
Hulu plus works on your computer,
your smart TV,
smart TV.
What the Hell's that?
Roku,
apple TV,
Xbox,
playstation.
Pretty much any streaming device you already own.
You can even watch on your iPhone or iPad while on a,
on a trend at work,
at the dentist or in the bathroom.
You can even block off a day to binge.
Um,
you'll also get an access to a Hulu originals that you can't get anywhere else.
Check out the new show.
Deadbeat comedy about a pot smoking guy who talks to ghosts.
I want to watch that binge on all 10 episodes starting April 9th for only seven
99 a month.
Get any shows you want anytime,
anywhere.
That's like a quarter a day.
People right now.
Sign up at Hulu plus.com/bill or click on the banner on my website and get two
weeks full access,
completely free.
That's a whole extra week more for this special offer when you sign up and Hulu
plus.com/bill so get with it and start streaming TV now with Hulu plus.
Um,
all right,
next one up here.
He voice
everyone what you want your business to make more money.
He voice can help.
Here's how when your customers call,
you'll have your own toll free number,
professional greeting,
dial by name directory and more.
You'll sound like a fortune 500 company and really stand out from competitors.
He voices lets you give out one number that rings wherever you are.
You can be at your kid's soccer game.
You'll never miss a chance to grow your business.
Eve always,
uh,
he voice even takes all your eat,
your voicemails,
transcribes them and sends them to you instantly as a text or email.
So you can check your voicemails before the meeting ends and not even look rude.
He voices only 13 bucks a month.
Right?
Now my listeners can try he voice for free for 60 days.
That's right.
A 60 day free trial.
Don't put this off.
Turn down the radio,
get to a computer and set up your ear voice 60 day free call now so you can see
what I mean.
Go to [inaudible] Dot Com Promo Code Bill.
That's [inaudible] dot com Promo Code Bill.
All right?
You know I hate when they do that.
Shut off the podcast right now.
The fuck I'm doing.
You guys solid here reading your ad.
Then you tell him to shut up my podcast.
You know what they did?
You know they sat there in that little,
okay,
what are their advertising cubicles?
Okay?
You know,
they just sat there going like,
problem is,
is they hear the ad and then they're listening to the rest of the podcast has
that data.
Well,
what if we told them to turn it off?
Then I'll go fuck yourself.
All right.
So anyways,
so,
um,
back to the tour.
So we're walking in and out of these bunkers and um,
oh my God,
he ain't even on the way there.
This tour was so good.
Like they had all like those,
uh,
I guess English people call them hedge rows,
you know,
back in the day to mark your property,
he grew these giant like rows of bushes.
Then,
I forget what they're called,
but they hit the guy actually let us get out and touch some of them.
They had like these,
these thorns on them that would just rip you to shreds
and um,
you know,
they would like seven,
eight feet high and could be upwards of eight feet across.
There was no way to get through them.
So I know when that saving private Ryan,
they showed a little bit of the fighting that was going on,
but you couldn't even see through them even today.
Most of them,
you couldn't even see through them.
So as you're walking up the road right on the other side and you could have been
an entire,
you know,
I dunno what do you call it,
a platoon or a division of Germans.
Uh,
it was absolutely insane.
So they used to send patrols out,
they tack a little way through it and they would send a patrol into these
fields.
And I guess the rule of thumb
and war,
which I,
you know,
I,
I don't know anything about it.
They never,
they never shoot at a patrol because then you only get like three,
four guys.
What you want the patrol to think is that it's safe and then they wait to the
entire company basically march is three quarters of the way into the field.
When they have nowhere to hide,
they would just mow him down and the Germans would put like just a couple of nes
machine gun nest could handle each one of these fields.
I mean,
it just seemed like after he got off the beach,
you're thinking like,
okay,
now it's going to get a little easier.
And it's just,
it was just a,
it was a shit show.
Basically,
so anyways,
um,
so we saw the initial,
uh,
area,
whatever the fuck that was called,
and then he's taken us down to Omaha beach.
And I got to tell you,
it was like,
uh,
you know,
it's crazy.
It's a famous beach.
You look at it and it's undeniable.
That's Omaha beach.
And this guy broke down the,
uh,
the entire thing.
You,
you know,
I didn't even feel worthy of like walking onto the beach like it,
it had like that level of effect on me,
which I,
I,
you know,
I did,
I didn't know what I was going to think when I got there,
but it was,
um,
it's incredible.
He shows you the pictures and then he starts pointing out on the bluffs with the
Germans were,
and how few that there were,
but I guess the bombing run,
we fucked it up.
We didn't do it right on that one where we did it much better on the other
beaches,
Utah and all that.
But we,
uh,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
It was,
it was,
uh,
if he,
if you can somehow get over here and do it,
you know,
all you gotta do is just get the plane ticket.
You can stay in a hostel,
have a banana,
this you're fucking breakfast,
jump on a train and go out there.
I highly suggest anybody who's
yeah.
Ever thought about doing it.
Uh,
you will not be disappointed.
And then in the end,
um,
the end of the tour,
he takes you up to this cemetery,
uh,
the American cemetery.
It's just,
it was,
it's unbelievable.
It's unbelievable.
And they play taps at the top of every hour and right as we got there,
that,
you know,
probably there for like three minutes and you look at it,
all of,
all of those graves,
all of those people that died trying to stop this maniac.
Okay.
And,
uh,
and then they play taps.
I mean,
it's overwhelming to say the least.
Um,
and then of course there's also the English cemetery,
which a lot of Americans don't know because we watch the American movies and
they make it seem like it was just the Americans who were over there.
Uh,
as always,
but you know,
something,
you know what the fucking,
this English guy downstairs was laughing,
giving me shit about how all the American movies,
like even Argo,
he goes,
you know,
uh,
the English and Dutch helped you guys out with that.
And I go,
well,
you know,
you guys will make your movie then.
And he's laughing.
I'm like,
you guys do it too.
I'm one time I was on
opie and Anthony,
the great opie and Anthony Radio program with little Jimmy Jamie door.
And these guys came in from England and they had made a documentary about,
uh,
the late great beast of a comic Bill Hicks.
And they were talking about how bill Hicks went to England.
That's where he had to go to get his,
his buzz going,
and then came back and took America by storm.
And he's sitting there saying,
[inaudible].
And he said this,
one of the documentary guys was going,
uh,
in while England was listening to Bill Hicks,
people in America were busy wasting their time listening to,
listening to carrot top.
And
I forget if I said it on air or not and I want to,
I was just like,
dude,
you realize that you're in America right now.
You do realize that.
So if you're going to spin these yarns,
like I was alive during this fucking time.
It's,
is that what I was doing?
And I'm not shitting on carrot top either.
I think the guy's flooding,
but like,
I was like,
oh,
I thought I was listening to Carlin and,
uh,
Sam Kennison.
I thought I really liked Sam Kennison and evidently I didn't.
Uh,
you know,
everybody does that shit.
You know,
we did everything and we understood and these guys were idiots.
So,
uh,
so fuck you English.
You know,
you do the same shit.
Anyway,
so
I've been over here too long.
I'm not going to lie to you.
As Fun as this is,
this is the most relaxed I've been in forever.
And uh,
but I am ready to go home and I'm ready to go back to work.
I'm ready to start telling jokes again,
and I miss the hell out of my dog.
I'm literally walking around.
Um,
every dog I see,
we're staying in this fucking,
uh,
Saint Tropez or as the locals call it central pay.
Uh,
yeah,
I know you're like Jesus Christ.
Bill.
I know this is the vacation and all fucking vacations.
I haven't taken one in forever,
so whatever.
I'm blowing some DVD money over here.
Um,
and I got to tell you something.
We're actually here.
It's this,
this summer season starts literally the day after we leave.
So it's kind of cool.
It's a lot of locals and people are just starting to trickle in.
And
do you remember that 50 cents?
Uh,
do you call it a song called the wrap is a called a ditty.
A P diddy.
I don't know what the fuck you call it,
but you remember that one.
I teach you how to stunt
and for people out there as white as me,
which means I basically
show you,
um,
how to blow all your money on depreciating assets and make yourself a target
every time you drive down the street.
Um,
I believe that that's what's stunting is,
um,
where you walk around with a chain that has a dollar sign on the end of it,
may not have some precious metal,
adds a smart thing to do.
Um,
and before all the racist people out there think I'm just talking about,
uh,
African Americans and not,
I'm talking about anybody that's new to money.
Like that's what you do.
Uh,
but these people out here,
rich,
old white dudes,
they do the same thing but in a much more subtle way.
They show off their fucking wealth.
It's fucking it.
First of all,
these French guys out here,
the heads of heroin,
these sons of bitches is incredible and they all have this same haircut.
It's like basically a,
how would I,
how would you describe it?
It's the,
it's like the hockey mullet,
but with a page boy quaff at the end of it,
it almost curls back into itself and then they,
they push it back.
It's like a mullet.
Yeah,
meets a number.
Remember Jackie Stewart,
the Formula One race car driver,
they all have that Irish spring fucking cut into some soap with the knife in the
70s haircut.
And um,
they have their beautiful wives and they have this sweater draped over him with
a fucking like,
and then they have like one piece on them,
be it a watch glasses,
but it's only one.
It's one thing that just says I have more money than fucking God.
And then the rest of it is just really neatly put together.
Um,
it's called having class people.
You know,
you don't sit on the hood of your new car holding up handfuls of cash and use
that as your fucking Facebook page.
That's what people do who just got money and always wanting money.
These cards here,
these frogs with their fucking money,
these guys,
um,
it's,
it's ridiculous.
And then every once in a while,
and Oh,
this is another thing that I like is their cars.
They're their whips.
What I like about these guys,
because they're,
they understand money and how it works.
Um,
they,
a lot of them bought some top of the line car like 20 years ago and just kept it
in an impeccable shape.
Like I saw this guy,
he had basically like the 1993 version of the Mercedes.
Uh,
what's the top end?
Big One there,
the ESL fucking whatever,
five 55 50.
He had the 1993 version of this and think pulls up absolutely immaculate.
It looks showroom,
brand new and he parked it and he got out and I was able to ask him in broken
French what year the car was,
um,
what would I say,
collage,
blah,
blah lotto or something like that.
And he just beamed with pride and he said 1993 and I was like three VN and he's
like,
you know,
it was,
it just,
he could,
he knew,
he knew.
Obviously it was some stupid American try to talk to him,
but he,
he uh,
I was really fucking cool this,
I've seen a couple of people over here,
they don't just buy out a flashy car.
Like they fucking loved that car and they keep it really nice.
I saw like a,
like a 1987,
um,
BMW like m five,
that was looked like in showroom condition.
Um,
so you've got that level of wealth.
And you know,
it's funny too is Nia has just been trashing me because I refuse to buy any
almond Santra pay close and I'm walking in my sweatpants and I got this hat that
I got at that Mario,
the new thing.
And I look like an asshole.
I'm not even gonna lie to you.
I mean,
I even like go to walk out and I see my dad jeans that I'm putting on.
I,
I really look like an asshole,
but I'll give a fuck.
They sit there and buy some salmon colored shorts,
right?
And some dumb sweater to drape over my fucking shoulders.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
you sit down along the fucking water and just one giant God damn boat after
another is sitting there.
And I'm trying to think like,
how much fucking money would you have to have this guy,
this guy,
he's going to fucking boat down there.
I swear to God,
it's gotta be like a $7 million.
It's a,
yet.
It's got a fly.
This guy,
this guy's book was so fucking big.
I'm sitting in the cafe and I'm,
I'm looking across the street,
across the sidewalk and into the back of this guy's boat and I'm watching.
I thought he was wanting,
this is fucking hilarious.
I thought he was watching a karate movie on his TV.
He was actually watching dancing with the stars.
It shows you what,
what is,
what has happened to karate movies.
They become too crouching tiger and not enough hidden dragon,
if you know what I mean.
You know,
I'd like to see a little more marked for death in my,
you know,
my movies and Judas Freelander always told me mark for death introduced the
breaking of bones into martial arts movies anyways.
And I,
yeah,
so I'm basically,
I'm sitting there and I'm watching this guy's TV on his fucking boat from a cafe
across the street.
That's how big this boat was.
That's how big that fucking TV was.
And it's just been parked there all week.
Or doctor,
whatever you say.
And,
um,
at one point I'm coming back into town to buy my 900 fucking cigar of the week
and I'm looking on the boat and I see a guy,
it's a chef on the boat,
dressed in like,
you know,
I'm going to go cook a gourmet meal.
I'm just saying like,
I'm,
how much is that cost a year?
Right?
You gotta give him at least 8,500 grand of fucking year to just be ready at any
no point.
Like to jump on your boat and make you a fucking sandwich.
And I,
I just want to fucking learn how to say,
permission to come aboard and French.
And I just want to find like,
how did you make that?
What did you do?
How the fuck do you have that level of money?
Right?
Is that nuts?
Sorry.
I hope I'm not boring.
You guys would this shit over it anyways,
so let's get back to the buy you think?
MMM.
We ended up going to this museum when we were there that had all this video and
all these pictures and that type of stuff.
And what was really cool
was,
um,
I'd never seen footage like this.
I think a lot of it was,
you know,
French footage.
And first of all,
their museum was way more inclusive.
Like it had,
it had the,
the,
uh,
American troops,
British troops,
Canadian troops and French,
the French troops and everything.
You know,
a lot of people like,
you know,
break the French balls,
my impression of a French soldier and you just put your arms up like you're
surrendering.
I guess it took the Germans like about five,
six weeks to take over France.
And in that time,
um,
France lost 90,000 troops,
not like casualty,
like dead.
That's not even just the wounded.
So they put up a hell of a fight.
But I gotta be honest with you,
if we live that close to the Germans,
we would have fucking lost.
Okay.
And we would need somebody to bail us the fuck out too.
And I know right now you go and give me a fucking break.
It's like,
fuck you.
Okay?
To this day,
look at their top end cars.
Look at our top end cars.
They're still kicking our ass.
I know the Cadillac Corvette,
that's probably the best we have,
but it's nowhere near what they would do with.
That was another thing that was great on the tour.
They were talking about how much better their weapons were.
So when we fucking kill a German,
we'd pick up their machine gun cause this shit was better than ours.
We basically,
we,
we fucking wore him down.
We just come and we came up with what happened and how we finally took the beach
on d day,
eat it.
They ran out of bullets.
We just kept coming
this fucking,
they call this guy the butcher of Omaha beach.
He was in this position that was,
they put a gun into the back corner of a hotel
and he was just fucking,
you know,
doing what [inaudible] wanted to do with the,
with this,
God damn,
I don't know what the fuck millimeter he had.
And he went through seven hours of ammunition and fucking three hours by the end
they was shooting like that weaponry where every third bullets of flair.
And that's how we ended up knocking out.
Could we finally could see where the fuck they were.
I mean,
it was just what happened on that day.
I,
you can't even fucking put it into words and then Dab a moron like me trying to
explain it.
MMM.
I,
I just,
I can't even imagine it.
I can't even fucking a man as much as like the beginning of saving private Ryan
shows it,
like just to actually just rather than watching some video or movie of it to
just be standing on the beach and this guy's telling you the stories showing you
the pictures.
Do it.
It was,
it was unbelievable.
Unfucking believable.
So anyways,
um,
I got water in my ear.
I've had it my fucking year and I've tried every goddamn thing.
I've tried blowing a hairdryer into my ear.
I've tried jumping on one foot.
I tried sleeping on my side.
It's great.
It's basically just gradually drying up.
And a,
I'm really hoping when I get on the plane,
my ears not gonna fuck with me.
Me Actually,
you know,
what's going on the Internet looking for fucking everything.
Like,
as I'm losing my mind,
I feel like I'm trapped in my own head.
That's how many,
how much water was in there and they were doing the shit.
Make a suction with your own hand.
None of that shit works.
So she finally reads it.
You see,
you go to the pharmacy and you get some,
uh,
alcohol and you squirt the alcohol in your ear and add on.
And I'm just like,
I'm going to put more liquid in there.
So I just decided to wait it out.
It's been driving me fucking nuts.
Anyways,
let's,
uh,
let's bang out of the last couple of,
does anybody have like anybody know anything that you can do to get water out of
your ear before I get on a plane and start screaming?
Is the air pressure changes as they pressurize the cabin?
Um,
anyways,
here we go.
Legal,
zoom.
Everybody.
Modern technology's great.
Smart phones,
iPads and other gadgets make it easy to do so many things.
But why is it that our lives seem busier at the same time?
I'll tell you why,
because you've got to download the new version of everything.
All right.
That's not part of this week.
Well,
when it comes to getting the legal help you need,
legal zoom provides a great solution that works with your busy schedule.
Let's face it,
the legal system is complicated.
There are better things you can do with your time.
Thankfully legal zoom is there for you,
so if you're thinking about starting a business,
forming an LLC or getting a trademark will or living trust,
legal zoom gets the job done right,
you'll get the personal attention you need and we'll help you take care of all
the details.
Legal Zoom has been helping families and small business owners for over 14 years
and they received an a plus from the better business bureau.
Call or visit legal zoom today for an extra discount and to burpee you are are
in the referral box at checkout.
That's legalzoom.com discount code burr legal zoom provides legal help through
independent attorneys and self help services,
but it is not a law from go to legalzoom.com enter the Discount Code
[inaudible],
B u r r and last but certainly not least,
the classic stamps.com everyone computers are designed to make running a
business easier,
including your mailing and shipping.
Just use stamps.com to get 24 hour,
24 hour access to the post office,
right from your computer.
No waiting in lines,
no hassles,
man stamps.com makes mailing and shipping easy.
Just use the computer and printer you're already have to get official US postage
for any letter,
any package.
Print the postage directly into your envelopes,
onto your envelopes,
labels,
even plain paper.
Then hand it to your mail carrier.
That's it.
There's no guesswork.
stamps.com we'll send you a digital scale that automatically calculates the
exact postage you need for any class of male.
You'll never have to go to the post office again.
I use stamps.com to send out all my DVDs and posters.
I'm a moron if I can use it.
So can you right now use my last name bur bur for this special offer,
no risk trial plus a $110 bonus offer that includes a digital scale and up to
$55 in free posters.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburburthatstamps.com enter
burr.
All right,
back to the,
uh,
back to the podcast here.
Um,
oh,
by the way,
everybody
over here,
it seems is either drives a fucking scooter or a God damn motorcycle and uh,
to the point we actually think it's safe,
but the dude downstairs is telling me they have more,
more damn accidents over here than anybody else.
But then I'm also thinking whether you got more people on scooters than anybody
else,
and you've got a ton of fucking money over here.
So you know what that means?
Does that means you basically you can go out and go buy yourself a bike that's
way beyond your capabilities,
right?
It also means that you have a complete disregard for 99% of human life.
Like most rich people do.
You have a sense of entitlement.
You're going to ride your fucking scooter and your motorcycle like that.
That's what I'm saying.
Why am I saying that?
Because I like riding motorcycles every once in a while and it scares the fuck
out of me that something bad's going to happen.
So what I do is I just justify it away in my head the same way I do when I smoke
a cigar gone.
I don't smoke that many of these fucking things.
You know?
It's what you always am not going to get cirrhosis of the liver.
There's plain isn't going to fucking all of a sudden make a left turn and then
nobody can find it.
That's what you do to get through life.
It's what you have to do.
Yeah.
She's not going to divorce me and take me for everything I got and I'm sure it
puts these claim.
Yeah,
it's only for chocolate by,
I'll hit the treadmill tomorrow.
Isn't that what you do?
The Shit.
You just justify it rather than sitting down go,
no,
this is a dumb thing to do.
This is going to make me fat.
I need to wear an extra condom.
Marsha,
probably just go jerk off.
You know,
maybe if you don't call somebody a gray haired cunt during all the chick flicks,
maybe she won't divorce you and take Kelly's shit.
Right.
You could do that.
That's,
that's called being an adult.
I think it's about time.
You all right talking to you right now,
the listener,
it's about time.
You guys fucking growed up.
Do you understand me?
I'm getting so fucking sick and tired now kid.
Um,
anyways,
oh,
a last week,
mmm.
Me and a,
the lovely knit at a,
one of our classic debates,
which is basically
the two of us talking over each other and then yelling,
stop interrupting me like most healthy couples do.
Um,
so anyways,
last week,
uh,
for those of you didn't listen,
what happened was some,
what happened was this guy sent an email and he was basically saying that the
woman has been dating for the last six years.
When they got together,
she was beautiful,
had an amazing body,
and now she has a new stressful job and she's put on like 60 to 70 pounds.
So he's talked to her about her weight.
He said he's concerned.
He bought our gym membership.
He's trying to get her healthy meals.
He packs her lunch.
He's going out of his way to try and help her out.
And uh,
evidently she's not going to the gym and he found some fast food wrappers
stuffed under the seat of her car or something.
And,
um,
and he's like,
what am I supposed to do?
And Nia flipped out on the guy and I defended the guy.
All right.
And then the listeners,
you guys,
you guys all chime did not all yet,
but a lot of you sent me emails and a lot of people gave me props.
Um,
for,
am I allowed to say that as a white guy gave me,
um,
compliments for staying in the pocket and not allowing myself to be railroaded.
And then they also criticize me as saying,
you know,
it's a big job.
Be,
feel beautiful,
intelligent.
Could just still only hear what she wants to hear at a,
I would throw that right back at you.
Right back at you.
It would be amazing that you can see her doing that and not notice that you're
doing the same thing.
Just as a guy,
you're doing the exact same thing that you're given a shit about.
You know
basically what happens there when you have a story between a man and a woman in
a relationship is you just insert yourself into the story.
So it was a guy,
who would you be?
You'd be the guy who had the hot girlfriend who now put on 60 to 70 and now has
is the guy said has sloppy tits.
Okay.
As a woman,
you listened to the story and you listen to,
I have a stressful job.
I'm putting on weight,
I'm doing the best I can.
And the person that I love just said I had sloppy tits.
So her reaction and my reaction were completely normal.
All right?
It has nothing to do with intelligence.
It just says to do,
you know,
it's like a fender bender,
right?
You know,
fuck can we are what you blow right through a stop sign and t bone somebody.
And when you get out,
the first thing you're going to say is what the fuck we had done.
Yeah,
yeah.
That stop sign was grade.
You're going to come up with some line of Bullshit.
So,
um,
whatever.
You know the deal,
everybody just fucking,
you know,
people here,
what the fuck they want to hear.
All right?
And they respond to it.
So I don't give a shit either way.
God bless you for listening.
But you know,
you don't have to say the,
I mean,
I don't mind you saying how she was being ignorant or whatever,
but some of it,
sometimes,
you know,
the Little Iga,
you gay,
you get a little disrespectful,
the level of derogatory that you fucking,
you take it too,
you know,
because you can be anonymous and as you sit there and your cubicle,
or maybe you have an office,
maybe the office guy,
right?
And you've got that little fucking thing there.
You know those marbles at the end of the the metal things and you're,
you're,
you're there on the pendulum and you fucking swing it and click,
click,
click.
Great.
Just taking away the second.
So the day,
whatever that fucking thing is called,
if you own one of those,
how soon before you get the giant globe in the corner,
that's something a hipster would do.
You know,
I really don't like about hipsters,
which is a really hacky thing to not like half the shit that they make fun of.
They don't even understand.
Like,
uh,
I've noticed a lot of hipsters say like,
they,
they're obsessed with tail fins on cars.
They think they're so cheesy that they're fucking awesome,
you know,
and they don't even understand the function.
I'm like back in the day with that technology,
you needed them.
Tailfin basically kept the rear end of the car at high speeds on the ground so
you could have more control and you wouldn't get fucking killed.
Now granted,
we put a tail fin on a fucking car that's never going to reach those speeds.
Yeah,
it is funny.
But a Nissan Maxima,
I mean I think you get up 120 miles an hour,
right?
It should have had a tail fin in the early nineties.
And people enjoyed it.
They liked them,
they looked cool.
So you stuck them on your car,
even if it didn't need one the same way you put rims on Adda don't going to be
fucking started with that shit.
Um,
so anyways,
um,
I'm probably going to cut this thing short this week because,
uh,
my internet connection is really horrific out here
to the point I'm going to have to send this podcast and sections because,
uh,
I got a bad feeling.
If I try to send the whole thing at once that I'm going to get three quarters of
the way through,
my Internet connection is going to crap out of me.
And,
uh,
that's going to be my day trying to send this fucking thing.
So,
um,
that is that as a podcast for this week,
I hope you enjoyed my little travel fucking diaries.
I don't know.
Next week I'll be back,
you know,
so or of Wa Abby.
At Doe.
Go Fuck Yourself.
That's the podcast for this week.
Next week I'll be back home and I'm really ready to go home.
I want to see my dog.
I want to watch some hockey.
You know,
I want to eat that American food that makes you fat.
I can't tell you something.
I'm eating like a fucking animal over here and um,
I barely put on any weight.
Okay.
All right.
I don't know what kind of poison is in our food over there in the states,
but I'm telling you,
I am eating like a fucking boy.
You know something over here you kind of nibble but you're doing it the whole
day.
Yeah.
Like all the lunch places close at two o'clock.
So then you have cafes and I always bringing out some sort of pastry or some
shit,
not Jesus Christ.
Listen to me sitting in a cafe and pastries.
What the fuck happened to me?
I gotta get back to the states.
Um,
I will be back next week and the podcast will sound at least semi professional.
I appreciate you guys tough on your way through these things.
And like I said,
once again,
if you ever get a chance to go visit Omaha beach,
you gotta,
you gotta do it.
You definitely got to do what?
I highly recommend it.
All right.
That's it.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you next week.